the book the comet of the tornado is if
anything a prequel you could say to the
last lecture it's the story of what's my
personal story of having come to
Carnegie Mellon in 1981 and my journey
through the years from from drama into
working with computer science and then
ultimately the entertainment Technology
Center but it's also the story of how
this rather wild crazy drama professor
got together with this in his own way
wild and crazy computer science
professor the title of the book Randy
named half of it because it was during
the last lecture when he was describing
his you know the six years that he and I
shared an office I mean our desks
weren't next to each other and in the
last lecture he is sharing an office
with Dawn was like sharing an office
with a tornado there was just so much
energy and you never knew which trailer
was next and I never had anybody refer
to be in that respect but the more I
thought about it the more I thought it
was correct but then if i had a moniker
of tornado what would be the moniker for
him I mean how would I describe Randy
especially since he was gone at that
point and comet came up because he he
just flashed upon the the world scene
and everyone saw him and and he left
this glorious trail of thoughts and
lessons and then disappeared into the
heavens I'm going to read a portion of
the book that that has to do with my
first experience my first encounter with
computers
my computer science experience had
actually commenced way back in nineteen
eighty-two that year IBM and Carnegie
Mellon reached an agreement whereby new
contraptions called personal computers
would be distributed throughout campus
to department heads and administrators
as assistant head of drama at the time I
was qualified to get one I remember
distinctly the day there was a knock on
my office door and I opened it to
confront a delivery man holding two
beige containers about the size of a
breadbox this is for you he said not
quite knowing what to make of the thing
I smiled blankly at him in motion to my
desk he placed the larger box containing
the computer on it capped off by a
smaller box containing a monitor he
connected some cables grunted and then
handed me an owner's manual about the
size of the Manhattan telephone book of
what am I supposed to do with this I
asked reader he said before exiting
since I am not fond of reading small
print volumes the size of the Gutenberg
Bible I placed the new toy and its
accompanying opus on a spare desk in the
corner and there they SAT some time in
the new year I was called into the
office of Aughrim Madadi and the Dean of
the College of Fine Arts Akram was a
mentor to me almost an idol he was a
veritable genius arrogant cunning
multilingual a college Pasha he beckoned
me to sit down and said done we have a
problem those are not words any
departmental administrator wants to hear
from the Dean we have reports you're not
using your computer he said it took me a
moment to figure out that he was
referring to the beige box collection in
the corner of my office being an actor I
feigned a front outraged and shocked at
this indignity declaring vociferously
that is an absolute lie I do use it you
do he replied genuinely surprised yes I
went on pausing for effect as a shelf
we both laughed but the point was made
I mean one of the really cool things
about the book is it uses a technology
developed here at Carnegie Mellon
synthetic interview and it's in the book
so the book comes with a printed copy
and then an interactive DVD and ideally
if you're interested enough about what I
wrote you're then able to put the DVD in
and ask me like 250 other questions
about life about about history about
philosophy and attitudes you name it as
a way of getting to know me more and
also what we do in the et see more and
if everything goes well now every book
will have to have a synthetic interview
in it and and then we'll rock will rock
big time so I'm very proud that a book
about the entertainment Technology
Center has technology in it
you